hello everyone and welcome to a truly
incredible game between vastly vancouver
and magnus carlsen from the uh hulu's
bear generation cup it is uh a very long
game so do not watch it if you don't
have the time it lasts for 120 moves but
it is quite a spectacle uh as uh of
course uh magnus is all considered to be
one of the greatest chess players who
ever lived alongside let's say gary
casparov and bobby fisher and well there
are you know if you have a top three
those are basically the top three if you
have a top five then you know everyone's
listing different but he's always in
there whereas uh chucky here he is
considered to be a player who can crush
any of those players you know on a good
day so any game against him is always
very interesting he's a very mysterious
person and uh well just
incredibly it's incredibly enjoyable to
watch his games so let's dive straight
into it and when i say uh the worst uh
moves or or the worst game i mean if
this was analyzed as a classical game of
course it's a rapid game so uh you know
with uh
uh
not so much time on the clock you of
course will miss things so you know take
that with a grain of salt as usual uh
when i say something so let's dive
straight into it the russell has the
white pieces and he opens with d4
knight to f6 by magnus we have c4 pawn
to e6 and everyone was very happy when
e6 was played because this is basically
not basically this is the same position
uh that was on the board where when
magnus resigned from han so maybe you
know everyone thought okay what is
magnus doing here but he played d6 and
then everyone was happy again so knight
to c3 and bishop to b4 and what more
could we hope for then to see a nimso
indian defense between
uh chalky and magnus so e3 going for the
for the normal line we have c5 c5 by
magnus and now knight to e2 bishop d3
always the more popular move but uh in
knight eight also very much played b6 we
have ponte a3 and now magnus goes back
bishop to a5
we have pawn to d5 and now we have
castles rook to b1 now preparing b4 to
trap the bishop here and of course
knight to a6 keeping an eye on that b4
square f3 magnus preparing to uh
artificially castle with king to f2 and
now there is a game where b5 was played
but here we have e captures and d5 by
magnet sorry i mean i meant uh vasel
ready to artificially castle with king
to f2 and magnus uh plays e captus on d5
which is a new move so already as of
move nine we have a completely new game
which is very exciting as this is the
nimzo indian defense so c captures on
the five by uh vassal we have pawn to b5
by magnus and now king to f2
and the king will be very safe here and
of course you just got the king away
from this nasty diagonal so very good so
rook to b8 by magnus again preparing
that b for push and pawn to e4 now
preparing e5 so magnus stops this we
have pawn to d6 and now bishop to e3 we
have knight to d7 and now we have knight
the g3 opening up the light square
bishop we have c4 and now only now
vassal strikes with pawn to b4 we have c
captures on b3 by magnus knight captures
on b5 now putting pressure on that a7
pawn and the magnus plays uh something
very very mysterious he plays queen to
f6 and he says all right you have your
a7 pawn and i'm gonna play something uh
uh well you probably uh will not guess
so bishop captures an a7 and now he
plays knight eat the c5 which knight a
to c5 which is awesome as he sacrifices
the exchange on b8 but um russell
doesn't want the exchange right away he
first wants to trade queens and magnus
is very happy with this as now he
doesn't have to sacrifice the exchange
so queen captures on d4 knight captures
and now he plays rook to a8 attacking
the bishop here bishop captures we have
knight captures and c5 and now knight g
to f5
uh just putting pressure on that d6 pawn
we have bishop to b6 and now as the king
might be very vulnerable here on f2 king
to g3 we have bishop captures on f5
knight captures and only now rook f2 d8
defending the d6 pawn bishop to c4
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game and now only now rook captures
on a3 as also the b3 pawn was under
attack so rook h to d1 and now pawn to
g6 chasing away the knight so 97 check
king g7 and knight to c6 and here comes
uh
the first brilliancy of the game from
vassel uh magnus has to play rook d to
a8 here but it seems like such a weird
thing to do so magnus plays a rook to c8
it makes sense the knight is here the
bishop is here but this allows vassal to
just play bishop captures on b3 and it
shouldn't be possible uh as the magnus
is defending the b3 square twice but it
is possible if if rook captures on b3
then rook captures knight captures
vassal just plays rook to b1 and he will
win back his piece he will keep the
extra pawn and retain a better position
and of course if we play knight captures
on b3 just rook d3 and again you are in
big trouble
so after bishop captures on b3 magnus
was very unhappy but okay the game has
to continue he plays bishop to d8 which
is very sad he just lost the past a b
pawn uh so bishop to d8 and now bishop
back to c2 we have bishop to f6 and now
rook to d2
rook c to a8 now the rook finally goes
to the square which where it should have
gone all along and now rook to e2
preparing at some point the bust open
the position rook the c3 putting
pressure on the bishop and just bishop
back to d1 we have pawn to h5 by magnus
and just king to f2 the king will be
very safe there so knights to d3 with
check king to f1 and now pawn to h4 we
have rooked the c2 now uh sorry rook the
c2 offering a a a trade of rooks rook
captures on c2 bishop captures on c2 and
now knight back to e5 offering a trade
of knights but just the bishop back to
d1 uh of course uh russell would be very
happy if magnus captured on c6 then he
just gets a nice past c6 pawn so rook a2
now saying okay now your king cannot
leave this square
but just bishop to e2 we have knights to
d7 now uh end pawn to g3 challenging the
structure but magnus just plays knight
to c5
and after rook to c1 he plays knight to
b3 attacks the rook here rook to d1 and
now pawn to h3 and now it could be very
dangerous now the h2 pawn is weak so
king to f2 we have bishop to b2 and this
bishop to b2 maneuver is spectacular
magnus's plan is the one from the
thumbnail he wants to play bishop to b
to the a3 to c5 the g1 and then pick up
the h2 pawn seems like a lot of moves
but uh if he can do it then he can do it
so bishop to b2 and now can just wait
and see what happens he has to create a
counter play so f4 e5 is coming bishop
the a3 with kink the e1 and now bishop
the c5
you would have to move the king out of
check
either way
so here we have pawn to e5 and now
bishop the g1 going after the h2 pawn
and just e captures on d6 and now
chucky already has d7 and d8 planned so
how can magnus stop this the best way to
stop it is bishop captures an h2
but magnus did not go for that he went
for knight to c5 first i i can even show
bishop captures on h2 and if d7 there's
bishop captures and g3 with check and
now after king f1 there's even knight to
d2 with check and now after king the g1
there's knight e4 and you cannot bring a
queen into the game it will be very very
hard to play this with white objectively
it's a draw but just uh for fun i will
show you what happens if queen is
brought into the game then comes root
captures on e2 and after a move let's
say queen you have to play something but
there isn't a good move you can play uh
whatever you play you're just gonna get
checkmated here there's uh the pawn is
coming and that's it for example you
play something weird you put the queen
let's say on d7 it's just a matter of
bishop to h2 check and now after the
king moves wherever knights the g3 will
be checkmate so uh you have to be very
very precise to actually draw this yeah
but okay after he captures on d6 magnus
went for knight c5 he says no reason to
even allow d7 and now we have rook to c1
putting pressure on that knight again
with the idea of maybe capturing pushing
d7 but now magnus finds bishop
characters on h2 very very strong move
we have rook captures and c5 grabbing
the knight and now bishop captures and
g3 check we have king to d1 and now pawn
to h2 now magnus's pawn is much much
closer to the queening square so bishop
to f3 must be played otherwise you're
getting checkmated and now rook to f2
again precisely played by magnus rook to
c2 now offering a trade of rooks and
here magnus plays rook to f1 with check
uh interestingly if you play rook
captures on f3 uh then uh it seems like
you are you are getting a pawn here but
rook captures an h2 was the idea
and if bishop captures an h2 there's
king e2 now attacking the rook not
allowing the rook any uh squares along
the third rank and if bishop captures on
f4 now not picking up the rook but
playing d7 and then after rook to a3
check king f2 bishop g5 guarding the
queening square you actually promote and
after bishop captures now you will pick
up the rook and you get this position
where magnus would be up upon in a very
very unpleasant position
uh just uh you know playing uh uh
pushing those past pawns and okay this
is also a pass pawn but the black king
is very close to it so i don't know
maybe with perfect play you can draw
this but it's very hard to say so after
rook c2 we have rook to f1 check by
magnus not going for this idea king the
e2 and now again you can repeat rook f2
check and go for what i've mentioned but
he didn't see it the first time so he
just goes rook captures on f3 now of
course if the rook is captured you bring
a queen into the game
but
uh what else are you going to do well
there is a move rook the c1 you you just
don't allow the queen to come into the
game
but uh of course that was not played in
the game in the game king captures and
f3 was played he allows magnus the queen
h1 queen with check king captures on g3
and now queen captures on d5 and this is
uh
the position that uh well it's just
unbelievable because uh well the threat
is queen to d3 check and then the rook
hangs now can can you do something about
this not really whatever you do the
queen will hunt the
white king along the board and uh you
will pick something up so here 95
guarding the d3 square preventing queen
to d3 check and the magnus actually
believes uh
vassal that this is uh possible
and the magnus just grabs a pawn when in
fact the queen the b3 check just picks
up the rook so yeah that was mister
queen captures on d6 uh it was
incredible time trouble here so of
course uh
players missed a lot of things rook to
c6 we have queen the a3 check knight to
f3 and now pawn to f6 so magnus can
still push for more than a draw here but
he has to be very very precise rook to
c4 uh we have king to f7 and now rook to
e4 russell will do his best to create
some sort of a fortress here queen to d3
attacks the rook rook d4 now chases away
the queen queen e3 just rook to d5 we
have king the e6 and now rook to b5
uh we have king to d6 uh and now rook to
a5 we have queen to c3 attacking the
rook but just rook b5 so vassal is very
happy just shifting the rook back and
forth uh king to c6 and now rook to b8
hoping to get rook to b8 uh rook the c8
check to pick up the queen but of course
magnus will not fall for that king d5
rook to g8 now going after the pawns and
king the e4 putting pressure on the
knight so you have to go back rookie 8
check king to f5 and now rook to e2 we
have queen to d3 now again attacking the
rook and rook to e1 we have g5 now
f captures on g5 and here magnus finds
queen to d6 check king g2 and now f
captures on g5 and here we have rook to
f1
which is kind of a good idea but it
allows magnus to push for the win only
if he finds the correct idea
but he doesn't magnus pushes g4 you have
to pin the knight first queen d5 let's
say now pins the knight and you are now
threatening g4 and this allows black to
actually win this for example king g3
queen to d3 now pinning the knight again
and after king g2 you pin the knight
again and after king g3 you pin the
knight again and after king g2 you push
g4 that's the only way to push g4 and
now it doesn't matter you do have some
discoveries you can even deliver a
double check but it doesn't matter for
example if knight h4 check you just play
king to g5 and the knight is trapped so
knight here obviously doesn't work and
what else is there if you play knights
the g1 check king g5 again and after
rook f2 you are hoping for some sort of
a fortress but after queen d3 and rook
repeating f1 king h4 we have rook f2
repeating now queen e4 check king to f1
and now g3 and after rook to b2 now it's
only a matter of delivering the proper
check and picking up the road because
the rook can no longer remain here so
let's say queen to f4 check king g2 uh
you waste the move king the g4 because
the
white knight doesn't have uh any good
moves you you can't move it here you
can't move it here and of course if you
move it here then the rook is no longer
guarding the f2 square so you have to
move the rook and once you move the rook
it's a queenie for checking f1 and queen
to be one check finally picking up the
rook
but okay like i said if this was a
normal game it was possible but players
are very low on time so uh queen d5 or
queen to c6 spinning the knight is the
way to go but magnus played the g4 and
now vassell can get a nice draw here if
he plays the correct idea and the
correct ideas are nice to d2 uh check
knights to d4 check uh but definitely
not knight to h for check with knights
to h4 it's still possible to win the
game for magnus but he has to move the
king
away from that pawn he has to play king
to e6 or king d5 however after king the
g5 is played which also seems like a
perfectly you know valid idea uh vassel
shows just what kind of a genius he is
and he finds the incredible incredible
fortress yes uh i i know what you guys
are thinking no wait there's a fortress
here uh but vassell finds it so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this uh incredible fortress idea
for vassal while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a true
genius much like vaslivanchuk is and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is knight to f5 that is the good
stuff and now magnus realizes that there
is no way of breaking through but you
have to see many moves ahead to realize
why this is a fortress and now avasta
will demonstrate why queen d5 check king
h2 we have queen to d2 check now comes
king g1 and queen to d3 seems like a
perfectly normal position you are
defending g3 you are ready to push g3
but this will this is what vassal found
when he played knight to f5 and it is
the only move that gets him a draw rook
to f2 this is the only move that allows
you to create a fortress because if you
move the king let's say you play king g2
then it's just a matter of queen h3
checking g1 and g3 and it's game over
however with rook to f2 it is impossible
to push g3 for the rest of the game
because if g3 now just knight captures
on g3 and if queen captures rook g2
attacks the queen of course the queen
cannot move uh the king is on g5 you
have to trade and it will be a draw by
insufficient material so after rook f2
magnus realizes that there is no way to
win this however he can play this for as
long as he wants it's a move 77 so he he
will of course continue pushing and he
will try every possible resource maybe
there's a hidden brilliancy maybe this
is not a fortress after all it is uh
more than more than famous that magnus
cross and does not believe in fortresses
so he starts king h5 we have rook h2
check king to g6 and now just rook back
to f2 nicely defending the knight making
sure g3 is forever impossible king g5
king to g2
queen h3 check just king g1 we have king
to f6 even uh
trying to get vassal to go for some sort
of a crazy check uh which he does he
goes knight g3 check king to e5 but now
just rook to g2 and as long as the queen
is here you have nothing to worry about
so queen h6 but now uh knight goes back
knight to f1 queen to b6 check now rook
f2 and now of course the g3 square is
again guarded by the knight we have
queen to b3 trying to trying to do
something but just rook the g2 now
attacking the pawn so king f4 and now
rook back to f2 check we have king the
g5 king to g2 and the king to h4 uh so
of course now you have to be careful uh
queen h3 might be might be problematic
so king the g1 now queen to b6 spinning
the rook uh and now of course g3 would
be very good but just keep the g2 we
have queen to d4 knights to g3 and now
queen to d5 with check king h2 we have
queen to d6 spinning the knight but it's
not a problem just rook g2 i i believe
vasa was enjoying this position very
much as if you find the fortress against
magnus carlsen uh you will sleep very
well tonight sir so knight's the g king
g5 we have rook to f2 and now we have
king back to h4 rook to g2 and the queen
to c7 keeping the pin but just rook g1
it's not is the only move but it's not a
very difficult one to find so king to g5
rook g2 king to f4 and now rook to f2
with check king to e3 king the g sorry
king to g2 and now queen to b7 with
check came to g1 queen to b1 with check
but just king to g2
uh was not about to get tricked now we
have queen to h7 uh again going for that
queen to h3 check but just knight to f1
check king to d3 and now uh king back to
g1 not not a worry in the world uh so
here we have queen a7 again pinning the
rook king to g2 unpinning queen to c7
and now knight to g3 so there is no way
of breaking through queen to b7 shark
king to g1 with king to d4 and now king
to h2 king to e3 attacking the rook but
just king to g1 defending queen to b1
check king to g2 and now queen to h7 we
have king to g1 queen to h3 and now
knight back to f1 with czech king e4
even a nice rookie 2 check king f4 rook
dev to check into g5 and now just rook
back to g2 uh queen to a3 now and of
course knight back to g3 with the exact
same setup so queen to c5 check rook to
f2 we have king to h4 and now king to g2
uh queen to d5 check king to h2 and now
queen to e5 uh hoping to win the night
but just rook g2 and after queen to f4
rook to g1 the only move but uh vassal
found it already so he will probably
find it again but with chucky you never
know so magnus of course will try uh
queen to f3 and not rook to g2 we have
king to g5 king to g1 and here we have
queen to e3 check and he was in this
position on move 122 that vastly when
shook and magnus carlsen agreed to a
draw as there is nothing more to be done
here or maybe it was even the 50 move
rule who knows i i wasn't keeping count
but either way uh magnus missed some
very very nice ideas there but uh once
uh you once he gave him an opportunity
he found but it really took a brilliancy
to spot that fortress and uh he was able
to pull it off so a big big
congratulations to vassell uh for
pulling this off
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and again uh big big
congratulations to everyone who found
rook to f2 here it's such a brilliancy
and also
if you found this uh
idea after king to g5 to to just go for
the knight to f5 maneuver to even allow
the position to reach that then you have
a bright future ahead of you uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done to two of them and
never failed to entertain uh i would
like to thank marcelo de barros uh paul
certainly chanted
francis here and paralyzed interior for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh until it finishes uh
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day